[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
over at patreon it's the 10th of
February and I wanted to hit you with an
album that I think it [__] took
everybody by storm this video took me by
storm [__] Smells Like Teen Spirit it
really did I didn't know what was going
on I'm like what the [__] all these
people jumping around and after a few
weeks I was like holy [__] the album
this week is Never Mind released I think
September 24th of 1991 it's Nirvana's
second album like I was telling Mike I
forgot the first album nobody a lot of
people don't know about the first album
because this just uh swept them off
their [__] feet you know this album
uh bad motor
finger [__] Pearl Jam Black whatever
the [__] 10 whatever it's called we just
featured that a few weeks ago you can't
feature that you can't feature anything
after 91 without talking about this
album This Album changed the game if you
talk to these guys I read in an
interview where and if you really think
about this album sounds great and they
said it was a mixture of like punk rock
the Smither remm and [__] like that I
just hear a little bit of the Smither I
don't hear no [__] RM in here I don't
hear nobody else in here I hear a
[__] band that I never heard before
to be honest with you that's what I hear
on here was I crazy about this album
when it first came out no but I wasn't
crazy about a lot of albums when it
first came out they got to grow on you
and sometimes you hear something that
you didn't hear the first time and you
visit again and go oh sh [__] I was
wrong I wasn't wrong about this album I
enjoyed this album I didn't know it was
going to be a [__] culture changing
album this is grunge this is it right
here this is the beginning of [__]
grunge and this album between you and me
this album could be a great as H album
what qualifies an album to be greatest H
album three good songs this one has like
six [__] good songs four of them that
[__] killed right like four four
songs on
[Music]
lium
lithium holy
[__] and also a lot of people don't know
this is Dave gr's first album with the B
and and Mike was saying they had a
guitar play or something this album is
great it's the 180 gauge Mike what' you
pay for it 20 bucks it's on [__]
Amazon 1,800 gauge it's heavy I mean it
probably doesn't give you the stuff the
original Al gave you I mean you got your
[__] sleeve but then you got this in
here and I've always liked these these
tell you little things I mean this
didn't tell me about Dave girl I just
remember it from the ow but what's here
in here is spring is here again tend to
age and Bloom he knows not what it means
sell the kids for food we can have some
more the water is so yellow I'm healthy
student you're my vitamins take your
time hurry up the choice is yours don't
be l i mean it's lyrics from the whole I
it's [__] great this is [__] great
when you so uh yeah this album let me
read you the [__] songs I love this
album cover if I was this kid I would
have sued too cuz my dick is out you
understand me I don't want nobody sing
with my dick is out when I'm [__] a
kid but this album has Smells Like Teen
Spirit In Bloom come as you are breathe
[Music]
lithium that's not much and you got poly
side two is terrestrial pissings drain
you tremendous Lounge act stay away
tremendous on a plane and something in
the
way it's their first album on subpop you
know as soon as I saw sub subp was the
first record this is the first time of
geing geing okay so they were always
subpop on this okay it's funny cuz when
I saw the sub pop on it brought back you
see that thing on stickers all over town
and all the tree stuff but no this album
is worth every penny for 22 bucks you're
out of your [__] mind if you don't
have this album you should be shot and
[__] hung you know this album started
it all this album I always talk about
what happened if Leonard skinnard
Wouldn't Die what would have happened if
this album was never come out what would
have happened if [__] proar Jam 10
had never come out or black or whatever
the [__] it's called because cuz I when
I think of those the grunge scene this
is my first thought and that's my second
thought honest to God sound Gard I
didn't think of till later Allison
Chains I don't think of till later this
is the album to [__] introduce you to
grunge tremendous [__] album I read
the songs it doesn't get no better than
this if you don't have never mind go
[__] your mother [__] suckers and put
your wings in wrench cuz you [__]
belong to each other have a great week I
love your suckers with all my heart
thank you very much patreon for enjoying
never
[Music]
mind
for